Sa palagay namin, ang mga quantum computer ay magpapahintulot sa amin na malutas ang ilang mga problema nang mas mabilis kaysa magagawa namin sa mga klasikal na computer lamang. Ngunit
ang pag-unawa kung paano ay mahirap. Ngayon sa Qiskit in the Classroom, susubukan nating matuklasan ang pinagmumulan ng kapangyarihan ng
quantum computing sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin sa isa sa pinaka-unang
algorithm. Maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the Classroom. Sa seryeng ito, gagamitin natin ang Qiskit para tuklasin ang ilang pundamental na
konsepto na karaniwang tinatakpan sa mga kursong may kaugnayan sa quantum computing. Ang bawat video ay sinasamahan ng isang interactive na module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan sa ibaba. Kaya tiyaking tingnan mo iyon. Kung marami ka nang narinig tungkol sa mga quantum computer, malamang
narinig mo na na maaari silang gumamit ng mga quantum phenomena tulad ng superposition, entanglement, at interference para malutas ang
mga problema sa mga paraan na hindi magagawa ng mga klasikal na computer. Ngunit paano eksakto nakatutulong ang mga katangiang ito? Noong 1985, si David Deutsch ang
una na nagpakita kung paano ito maaaring mangyari. Nalikha niya ang tinatawag na Deutsch's algorithm na kayang malutas ang isang
problema nang mas mahusay kaysa sa isang klasikal na algorithm. Ngayon, titingnan natin ang Deutsch's algorithm at
isang susunod na extension na tinatawag na Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm at susuriin kung paano ang natatanging quantum na aspeto ng mga qubit
ay maaaring magamit para sa kapakinabangan ng quantum computer. Pagkatapos ay papatakbuhin natin ang mga algorithm na ito sa isang tunay na quantum computer gamit ang Qiskit.
May iba pang mga quantum algorithm na nagpapakita rin ng teoretikal na kalamangan kaysa sa mga kilalang klasikal na algorithm. At hindi lahat ng ito ay gumagana
sa parehong mga prinsipyo gaya ng makikita natin ngayon. Kaya ang matututunan natin ngayon ay hindi nagpapaliwanag sa pangkalahatan kung paano gumagana ang isang quantum
computer, ngunit nakakatulong ito sa amin na magsimulang makita kung paano maaaring pagsamahin ang mga prinsipyo ng quantum mechanics para
makagawa ng makapangyarihang quantum computer. Bago sumisid sa Deutsch's algorithm, pag-isipan muna natin kung paano naiiba ang mga quantum computer
sa mga klasikal na computer at kung paano iyon maaaring magbigay sa atin ng kalamangan sa paglutas ng ilang
mga problema. Isang pagkakaiba ay ang mga quantum bit na tinatawag na qubit ay maaaring nasa superposition na estado. Sa halip na
limitado sa alinman sa zero na estado o sa one na estado gaya ng isang klasikal na bit, ang isang qubit
ay maaaring nasa superposition na estado ng parehong zero at isa. Isinusulat natin ang estado na ito
ganito kung saan ang a at b ay mga kumplikadong numero na ang mga square ay nagdadagdag sa isa at ang mas marami
pang qubit ang mas lumalawak ang agwat na ito. Dalawang bit ay maaari pa ring nasa isa lamang sa mga ito
apat na posibleng estado. 0 0, 1, 1 0 o 1
1. Dalawang qubit ay maaaring nasa superposition ng lahat ng apat na klasikal na pinapahintulutang estado na
isinusulat ganito. Sa pangkalahatan, ang isang klasikal na sistema ng n bit ay maaari lamang nasa isa sa 2 sa kapangyarihan n posibleng
kombinasyon ng mga zero at isa. Ang isang quantum sistema ng n qubit ay maaaring nasa superposition ng lahat ng 2 sa kapangyarihan n ng mga
estado. Ang scaling ay exponential. Kaya kahit 10 qubit lamang ang mayroon tayo,
maaari silang nasa superposition na estado ng 2 sa kapangyarihan 10, na 1,024 posibleng kombinasyon ng mga zero at
isa. Ang exponential scaling ng state space ng mga qubit ay tinatawag na quantum
parallelism at bahagyang responsable sa kalamangan ng mga quantum computer kaysa sa mga klasikal na computer. Ngunit ang isang quantum
computer ay hindi lamang isang malaking parallel processor. Ang katotohanan na ang mga qubit sa isang quantum computer ay maaaring nasa
superposition ng exponentially maraming estado ay hindi nangangahulugang may access tayo sa lahat ng impormasyon sa bawat isa sa mga
estado. Dahil ibinabagsak ng sukat ang sistema sa isang estado o iba pa,
tingnan natin kung paano ito naglalaro sa isang simpleng problema. Sabihin nating may makina na
maaari mong paglagyan ng isang bit. Pagkatapos ay mag-a-apply ito ng ilang function sa bit at maglalabas ng isa pang bit. Ang makina
ay nasa loob ng isang black box na hindi natin ma-access. Ang tanging access lamang natin ay ang bit
na pinapasok natin x at ang bit na inilalabas ng kahon na f
ng x. Gusto nating malaman kung ano ang function na f na inilalapat ng makina.
May apat na posibleng function na nagdadala ng isang bit sa isa pang bit.
Kaya para malaman kung ano ang function, maaari nating paglalagyan ng zero at tingnan kung naglalabas ito ng zero o isa. Pagkatapos paglalagyan ng
isa at gawin ang parehong bagay. Ang bawat isa sa dalawang hakbang na ito ay tinatawag na query. Ito
ay isang paraan para ikumpara ang mga klasikal at quantum algorithm sa pamamagitan ng tinatawag na query model kung saan inihahambing natin ang bilang
ng mga query na kailangan ng bawat algorithm na gawin sa black box para malutas ang problema. Kaya sa kasong ito, ang aming
klasikal na pamamaraan ay kailangang mag-query sa kahon ng dalawang beses para malaman ang function. Tingnan natin kung magagawa natin nang mas maayos kung mayroon tayong quantum
computer na mag-query sa black box. Sa halip na una ay maglagay ng zero at pagkatapos ay isa, ang
quantum computer ay maaaring maglagay sa kahon ng isang qubit na nasa superposition ng zero at
isa. Kaya sa epekto, pinapasok natin ang kahon ng parehong input sa isang query. Pagkatapos ay
nangangahulugan ba iyon na matututunan natin ang function sa isang query lamang?
Sa kasamaang palad, hindi iyon ang kaso. Makikita natin kung bakit nabigo ang ideyang ito kapag sinubukan natin ito sa isang quantum computer. Gagawa tayo ng
circuit na may dalawang qubit. Ang qubit zero na kinakatawan dito ng tuktok na linya ay ang aming input na estado X na pinapasok natin sa
black box na ipinakita dito ng maroon gate na may label na UF. Ang UF gate ay
dinisenyo para kumuha ng qubit zero bilang input na estado X at pagkatapos ay mag-apply ng transformation sa qubit isa na nagdadala
ng estado zero sa estado f ng x. Kaya basta nagsimula ang qubit 1 sa estado
zero, ang output ay x sa qubit 0 at f ng x sa qubit 1. Kaya para mahanap ang f ng x para sa
parehong x=0 at x= 1 nang sabay, maaari nating subukang ilagay ang qubit 0 sa superposition ng 0 at 1 bago
ipasok ito sa black box. Iyon ay ginagawa ng pulang Hadamard gate na ito na nagbabago ng zero na estado sa 1 / 2
0 + 1. Kaya pagkatapos ng blackbox gate, dapat na mayroon kaming superposition ng parehong
f ng 0 at f ng 1 sa qubit 1. Kapag sinukat natin ang dalawang qubit, umaasa tayong
masagot ang tanong, anong function ang nasa loob ng black box. Gamitin natin ang Qiskit primitive sampler para patakbuhin ang
circuit at ibalik ang resulta. Maaari tayong pumili ng bilang ng beses na pinapatakbo ang circuit na tinatawag na mga sample sa pamamagitan ng pagbabago ng
parameter na tinatawag na shots dito.
Ito ay katumbas ng bilang ng mga query na ginagawa natin sa black box. Tingnan natin kung sapat ang isang query
na magagawa. Narito ang resulta. Sinukat namin ang qubit 0 na zero. Kaya iyon ang
input na halaga x at ang qubit 1 na 1, na siyang output na halaga f ng x. Kaya ngayon
alam na natin na ang f ng 0 ay katumbas ng 1. Ngunit paano naman ang f ng 1? Dito nandoon ang problema. Kapag
sinukat na natin ang estado, naguho ang mga superposition at nakakuha lamang tayo ng sukat ng isang bahagi ng function sa
isang query. Hindi nito nasasabi sa atin ang lahat ng kailangan nating malaman para matukoy kung aling function ito. Kailangan natin ng
ikalawang query sa kahon para doon. Kaya kahit pinapayagan ng quantum parallelism na sabay na
ipasuri ng black box ang f ng 0 at f ng 1, wala tayong access sa pareho sa
mga sagot. Ang quantum parallelism lamang ay hindi sapat. Ipinapakita ng Deutsch's algorithm
kung paano natin magagamit ang quantum parallelism nang kaunting naiiba para matuto tungkol sa function sa loob ng black box. Hindi
tayo makaka-alam nang eksakto kung ano ang function, ngunit matututunan natin ang isang bagong bagay tungkol dito sa isang
query na hindi natin magagawa sa isang klasikal na computer. Magsimula tayo sa pagtingin sa isang chart ng apat na posibleng
function na nagdadala ng isang bit sa isa pang bit. Dito makikita mong ang dalawa sa mga function na f_sub_1 at f_sub_4 ay laging
nagbabalik ng isang halaga anuman ang input na estado. Tinatawag natin ang dalawang function na ito
na constant. Ang f_sub_2 at f_sub_3 ay magbabalik ng alinman sa zero o isa depende sa
estado ng x. Tinatawag natin ang dalawang function na ito na balanced. Tinutukoy ng Deutsch's algorithm
kung ang function ay constant o balanced sa pamamagitan ng ilang matalinong pagbabago sa circuit na ginamit natin
dati. Narito ang circuit. Nagsisimula ito sa pamamagitan ng paghahanda ng qubit 0 sa estado 1 /
2 0 + 1 gamit ang Hadamard tulad ng dati at qubit 1 sa estado 1 / 2 0 - 1
gamit ang not gate na sinusundan ng Hadamard.
Kaya ang buong estado sa puntong ito dito ay kung saan ito ang estado ng qubit 0 at
ito ang estado ng qubit 1. Ang paghahanda ng qubit isa sa ganitong paraan kaysa sa pag-
iwan lamang ito sa estado zero ay nagbibigay-daan sa algorithm na gamitin ang quantum parallelism kasabay ng interference para matuto
tungkol sa blackbox function. Tingnan natin kung paano kapag pinapasok ang mga qubit sa UF na blackbox gate maaaring mangyari ang ilang bagay.
Kung ang function ay constant, ang black box ay magsasagawa ng ilang operasyon sa qubit isa lamang anuman
ang estado ng zero. Sa kasong ito, dahil hindi hawakan ng UF ang qubit zero o
pinapansin ang estado nito, ang pangalawang Hadamard dito ay isinasaklaw lamang ang ginawa ng
unang Hadamard. At susukat tayo ng qubit na nasa estado zero. Tingnan natin ang balanced function na f_sub_2 bilang halimbawa para makita
kung ano ang ginagawa ng uf sa estado sa kasong ito. Kapag ang x ay zero, ang f ng x ay zero at kapag ang x
ay 1, ang f ng x ay 1. Alalahanin ang sinabi ko sa iyo tungkol sa uf gate. Kinukuha nito ang qubit 0
bilang aming input x na estado at inilalabas ang f ng x sa qubit 1. Ipagpalagay na ang qubit 1
ay nagsimula sa zero na estado. Kaya para sa function na ito, ang ginagawa ng UF sa qubit 1 ay depende
sa qubit 0. Kung ang 0 ay zero, ang qubit 1 ay mananatili sa zero na estado para makuha ang f
ng x= 0. Kung ang qubit 0 ay 1, ang black box ay mag-a-apply ng not gate sa qubit 1 at ilalagay
ito sa estado isa. Kaya makukuha natin ang f ng 1 na katumbas ng 1. Ito ay eksakto ang ginagawa ng controlled not o c not gate. Ang
c not gate ay kumukuha ng dalawang qubit, isang control qubit at isang target qubit, at nag-i-flip ng
estado ng target qubit kung ang control qubit ay nasa estado isa. Ngunit wala itong ginagawa sa target kung ang control
qubit ay nasa estado zero. Kaya ang UF para sa F2 ay isang c not lamang sa Q0 at Q1. Ang c
not gate ay walang gagawin sa unang termino dahil ang control qubit ay nasa estado zero. Ngunit sa pangalawang termino, ang
zero ay nagiging isa at ang isa ay nagiging zero. At kung mag-factor tayo ng minus sign, makikita natin na ang estado ng qubit 1 ay
walang pagbabago. Ngunit ang termino na ito ay nakakuha ng minus sign. Kaya ang estado ng qubit 0 ang
talagang nagbago. Nagbago ito mula sa 0 + 1 patungong 0 minus
isa. Kapag nag-apply tayo ng huling Hadamard sa qubit 0, binabago nito ito sa estado 1. Kaya kung ang function sa black box
ay f_sub_2, susukat tayo ng isa sa halip na zero. Lumabas na ang UF gate para sa iba pang balanced function na f3 ay ang
parehong c not gate na sinusundan ng not sa qubit 1. Ang huling not gate ay hindi nakakaapekto sa qubit zero. Kaya kapag ang function
ay balanced, susukat tayo ng qubit 0 na nasa estado isa sa pagtatapos ng circuit. Ngayon kung hindi mo nasundan ang lahat ng
ito, okay lang iyon. Iminumungkahi kong dumaan ka nito nang mag-isa para makita kung paano ito gumagana. Ang pangunahing punto dito ay kung ano ang
nangyari nang nag-apply tayo ng c not para sa dalawang balanced function. Ang qubit 0 ay ginamit lamang bilang control qubit para baguhin
ang estado ng qubit 1. Ayon sa intuisyon, maaaring isipin mo na ang qubit 0 ay mananatiling hindi nagbabago. At gayunpaman, sa ilang paraan ang ating
mga operasyon sa qubit isa ay talagang binabago ang estado ng qubit zero sa pamamagitan ng pagbabago ng relative phase sa pagitan ng dalawang bahagi ng
superposition nito. Ang penomenong ito ay kilala bilang mekanismo ng phase kickback at ito ay
sobrang counter-intuitive tulad ng maraming quantum phenomena. Sa isang paraan, maaari mong isipin ang phase kickback mechanism
na parang pagsagwan ng bangka. Ang kilos ng pagtulak ng tubig pabalik ay talagang nagpapasulong sa iyo. Tulad ng mga operasyon sa
qubit 1 na talagang nagbabago ng qubit zero. Ngayon maaari na nating patakbuhin ang Deutsch's algorithm sa
Qiskit. Dito maaari tayong pumili kung aling function ang ilalagay sa loob ng black box na pinili nating maging F3. Narito ang
circuit diagram ng algorithm at maaari nating patakbuhin ito tulad ng dati gamit ang sampler primitive. Itatakda natin ang bilang ng
mga sample sa isa lamang at tingnan kung ano ang ating sukat. Sa kasong ito, sinukat namin ang isa.
Kaya, alam na natin na ang function ay balanced, na totoo nga ang inaasahan natin dahil ang black box ay naglalaman ng function na f3. Kaya, sa isang
query lamang, nagawa nating ibukod ang dalawang klase ng function na ito.
Kailangan ng isang klasikal na algorithm ng dalawang query para matukoy ito. Nagpapakita ito ng katamtamang kalamangan ng quantum
computing kaysa sa klasikal na computing lamang, ngunit hindi ito napaka-kahanga-hanga. Isa lamang versus dalawa. Ngunit ang Deutsch's algorithm
ay napakahalaga pa rin sa kasaysayan ng quantum computing dahil nagbigay ito ng inspirasyon na nagpapalakad sa iba
na mag-isip tungkol sa mas malalaki at mas sopistikadong quantum algorithm.
Kasama dito ang isang multi-qubit na extension ng Deutsch's algorithm na nagpapakita ng mas kahanga-hangang quantum advantage.
Ito ay tinatawag na Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm. Nireresuelba nito ang katulad na problema, ngunit sa kasong ito, ang blackbox function
na gusto nating matutunan ay kumukuha ng n bit bilang input at naglalabas ng isang bit. Gaya ng
dati, ipinangako sa atin na ang function ay alinman sa constant, ibig sabihin ang output bit ay laging isa o laging zero,
anuman ang input bit string, o balanced, ibig sabihin ang output ay zero para sa
kalahati ng mga input bit string at isa para sa ikalawang kalahati. Mayroong, siyempre, iba pang
mga function na nagdadala ng n bit sa isang bit na hindi constant o balanced. Ngunit sa problemang ito, ipinangako sa atin
na wala sa mga function na iyon ang nasa loob ng black box. Ang nasa kahon ay garantisadong alinman sa constant
o balanced. Ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit ay katulad ng Deutsch's algorithm, ngunit may mas maraming qubit. Dito mayroon kaming isang
implementasyon ng Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm para matuto tungkol sa isang tatlong-bit na function. Sa pagkakataong ito mayroon kaming tatlong qubit
para sa input na estado sa halip na isa lamang. At pagkatapos ay mayroon kaming huling qubit na ito para sa output na estado. Gaya ng dati, muli
inihahanda natin ang lahat ng input qubit na nasa estado 0 + isa at ang output qubit
na nasa estado 0 minus isa. Pagkatapos kahit ang matematika ay medyo mas kumplikado, ang prinsipyo
ay nananatiling pareho. Kung ang function ay constant, hindi ito maaaring mag-depend sa tatlong nangungunang qubit. Kaya ang kanilang mga estado
ay magbabalik sa zero pagkatapos ng ikalawang Hadamard at ang aming sukat ay magbubunga ng tatlong-bit na string ng lahat ng
zero. Ngunit kung ang function ay balanced, kapag sinukat natin ang mga qubit kasunod ng mga Hadamard, ang phase kickback
mechanism ay magiging sanhi ng isa o higit pa sa mga bit na maging isa. Maaaring hindi iyon kasing dali makita sa pagkakataong ito ngunit kung gagawa ka
ng bawat hakbang nang mag-isa, mabilis mong makikita na ito ay dapat na ganoon. Isang paraan para suriin ito ay ang subukang kalkulahin ang
probabilidad ng pagsukat ng lahat ng zero gamit ang isang balanced function. Dapat kang makakuha ng probabilidad na zero. Patakbuhin natin ang
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm sa isang quantum computer gamit ang Qiskit. Ang pinakamahirap na hakbang ay malamang na ang paglikha ng Deutsch-Jozsa
function. Iyon ang magiging aming black box na ina-query natin dito. Ang code na ito ay gumagawa ng random na Deutsch-Jozsa function na
garantisadong alinman sa balanced o constant. Pagkatapos ay ginagawa natin ang aming Deutsch-Jozsa circuit na inilalagay ang aming black box
function dito. Muli, pinapatakbo namin ang circuit gamit ang sampler at pagkatapos naming sukat, tinitignan namin
ang mga nasukat na bit para matukoy kung ang function ay balanced o constant.
Kung lahat sila ay zero, ito ay constant. Ngunit kung mayroong kahit isang bit na isa sa string, balanced ito. Sa
kasong ito, nakakuha tayo ng bit string na 1 isa isa.
Kaya, alam nating ang function ay balanced. Umaasa akong nabigyan kita ng iyong unang sulyap sa kung paano ang mga quantum algorithm
ay maaaring samantalahin ang mga kawili-wili at madalas na banayad na quantum phenomena para makamit ang kanilang kalamangan kaysa sa klasikal na
mga algorithm. Malamang na napansin mo rin kung gaano kahirap ang pagdidisenyo ng mga quantum algorithm. Kahit ang pinaka-una
ay nangangailangan ng maraming pagkamalikhain para makamit ang isang katamtamang tagumpay lamang laban sa mga klasikal na pamamaraan. At mula pa sa unang algorithm na iyon,
ang mga pisiko at siyentipiko ng computer ay patuloy na gumagawa ng mga kahanga-hangang paraan para gamitin ang quantum mechanics
para sa kanilang kalamangan, kabilang ang mga karagdagang extension at aplikasyon ng Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm. Kung gusto mong
matuto tungkol sa ilan sa mga ito, pati na rin subukan ang Deutsch at Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm para sa iyong sarili, pumunta sa
module na naka-link sa paglalarawan para magsimula. Salamat sa panonood at hanggang sa susunod.